>> Laura: IF YOU LOOK
CAREFULLY, YOU'LL NOTICE MEDIA
LEADERS ON THE LEFT ARE SLOWLY
CHIPPING AWAY AT THIS IDEA OF
MASCULINITY, AND OTHER WORDS,
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A MAN.
DON'T BELIEVE ME?
CHECK OUT THIS DISCUSSION ON
MSNBC.
>> TELL THEM TO "MAN UP."
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> NO CLUE.
>> NOT SHOWING EMOTION.
>> WHAT IS THE HARDEST PART
ABOUT GROWING UP FOR BOYS?
>> HIDING THE PAIN.
>> YEAH.
NOT BEING ABLE TO EXPRESS
YOURSELF.
>> Laura: OH, MY WORD.
SO THE PROBLEM IS MASCULINITY.
AND IT'S NOT RESERVED FOR
LEFT-WING CABLE SHOWS.
HERE IS FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> A LOT OF OUR PROBLEMS ARE
CAUSED BY OLD MEN.
NO OFFENSE, MEN WHO ARE OLD.
>> Laura: HE IS NOT EXACTLY A
SPRING CHICKEN.
COME ON.
BRING IN LIBERAL ANALYSTS --
I'LL NOT CALL YOU A LIBERAL
ANALYST.
YOU'RE AN ANALYST.
>> YOU COULD CALL ME
LEFT-LEANING, I WOULD SAY.
>> Laura: HOW ARE YOU?
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
WHEN I HEAR THESE ATTACKS ON
MASCULINITY, HERE THE LEFT
EQUATING MASCULINE, WHAT IT MEAS
EQUATING MASCULINE, WHAT IT MEAT
EQUATING MASCULINE, WHAT IT MEAO
BE MASCULINE WITH
ABUSIVE OR CRIMINALITY.
WE ARE ALL AGAINST ABUSE, WE ARE
ALL AGAINST CRIMINALITY, LIKE WE
SHOULD BE.
FOR ME, WHEN YOU SAY SOMEONE IS
MASCULINE, IT DOESN'T -- I DON'T
SEE THAT.
I DON'T WANT THAT, NO ONE I NO
BOND SET, BUT IT'S OKAY FOR A
MAN TOO, AS A FRIEND OF MINE
SAYS, PROTECT, PROVIDE, AND
DEFEND, AND I'M SORRY, MOST
WOMEN I HAPPEN TO KNOW LIKE MEN
WHO LIKE TO DO THAT, THAT CARRY
THEMSELVES THAT WAY AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY THINK THEIR ROLE IS.
TODAY IN SCHOOLS AND DISCUSSIONS
LIKE WE SAW ON MSNBC, THAT IS
CONSIDERED KIND OF ICKY, THAT
WHOLE CONSTRUCT IS OPPRESSIVE,
WHY IS THAT?
>> I THINK THERE IS NOTHING
NECESSARILY WRONG WITH, YOU
KNOW, A MAN WHO WANTS TO PROTECT
AND DEFEND.
THAT SPECIFIC SEGMENT WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
RIGID GENDER ROLES, SPECIFICALLY
IN BOYS, ARE TIED TO HIGHER
RATES OF SUICIDE, SUBSTANCE
ABUSE, VIOLENCE.
BASICALLY SAYING THAT GENDER
ROLE, THEY BASICALLY FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN'T EXPRESS THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: HOW IS THAT
CONNECTED.
WE HAVE HAD GENDER ROLES FOR, I
DON'T KNOW,
MELANIA.
LIKE GENDER ROLES ARE, TOSSING
WAYS TO COMMIT SUICIDE, MAYBE
THERE ARE A LOT OF FACTORS IN
DRUG ABUSE, PROMISCUITY, AND,
YOU KNOW, SHAMING, AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTION,
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTIONV
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTIOND
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTIONO
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTIONG
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTIONM
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTIONS
ABUSE OF OTHER TYPES, ADDICTION,
ISOLATION BECAUSE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA, FAMILY DISSOLUTION.
MEN HAVE BEEN MASCULINE FOR A
LONG TIME, BUT THEY FEMINISTS
ARE LIKE, IT'S MASCULINITY
CAUSING THEM TO DO ALL THAT.
>> IN THE FEMINIST COMMUNITY, WE
TALK ABOUT HOW GENDER ROLES TEND
TO HOLD WOMEN BACK, BUT THERE IS
ALSO SOMETHING ABOUT HOW GENDER
ROLES TEND TO HOLD MEN BACK.
MEN ARE TAUGHT FROM A YOUNG AGE,
A VERY YOUNG AGE, PRESCHOOL AGE,
THAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
UNEMOTIONAL, MACHO, AGGRESSIVE.
BECAUSE OF THAT, THEY DON'T
REALLY HAVE THAT HEALTHY BALANCE
FOR AN OUTLET OTHER ANGER,
FRUSTRATION, THINGS ARE
SENSITIVE ABOUT, RAGE, THINGS
THEY ARE FEELING, AND BECAUSE OF
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO M
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO K
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO E
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO I
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO S
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO L
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO F
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO E
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO ,
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO A
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO D
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO Y
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO S
THAT, EXPRESSES THEM SULTAN TO ,
THERE ARE OTHER FACTORS AT PLAY,
BUT OFTEN EXPRESSES ITSELF
THROUGH VIOLENCE AND TURNING
INWARD THROUGH DEPRESSION,
SELF-HARM, SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S THE ONLY
CAUSE, BUT --
>> Laura: MAYBE IT IS SOCIETY
MAKING THEM FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
ALL PREDATORS.